hey everybody and welcome to a dangerous
wild ride with stevo this week's guest
louis gomez just doesn't care it's
almost like he's trying to get canceled
that's even what he says geez it's nuts
and of course you know him from the
legion of skanks in the comedy world
also as the controversially ousted
co-host of the believe you me podcast
with michael bisping so yeah this gets
juicy and we get way
way into talking about sex addiction so
let me say it gets really juicy and
speaking of juicy can i tell you that
liquid death is saving the world it's a
canned water company and the reason why
it's canned is because they're very
angry at plastic
plastic is destroying the environment
and their infinitely recyclable and
super cool look like beer cans of water
are saving the world man i love this
company they're fun and if you order any
amount of water or merch from their
website you will get free shipping if
you add a little stevo that's
liquiddeth.como
for free shipping on all of your orders
of water and merch it's the best deal
going i drink it all the time i love it
and it's way better than soda so switch
to liquid death and enjoy their new
flavors but enough of that let's get
into it
ladies and gentlemen louis j gomez
yeah dude
good to see you good to meet you good to
officially meet you we did the bisping
podcast together
but never officially met before
obviously
right uh i'm a legend so you must be
very excited super excited now you've
met uh scott ramsey another legend
another legend two legends and stevo at
one table it's crazy i love it
and uh having never actually
physically met you in person
uh to see you i was like whoa like what
a substantial guy oh i know i'm a bigger
dude than people think something i
wasn't prepared for how uh imposing well
i also hugged you and i got risk control
like we were in
trouble it's just i i have to let people
know very quickly that i could take risk
control and it could go south at any
moment it's a psychological thing you
and scott have that in common preaching
to the choir over here
i'm a white belt been doing uh six
classes with jean-jacques mcadam
oh so i just got my blue belt i'm new as
well
yeah but i love it dude it's so much fun
am i correct that you were uh scheduled
or actually did
uh fight jason ellis so all right me and
ellis um
who i love he's the [ __ ] man
we are currently scheduled to fight uh
an mma fight a professional mma fight
he's done two professional mma fights
i've never done a professional how old
are you i'm 40. he's 50 though he just
looks better yeah yeah i don't think he
necessarily looks better than you i
think that's uh
outrageous and regardless of what you
look like yeah i mean you shouldn't be
fighting at
50 years old nobody should be fighting
it's a psychotic thing that i'm doing
but i want to challenge myself me and
him did like a boxing exhibition and i
did pretty good i held my own with him
um and uh i fought at his event he
doesn't an event called ls mania every
year and it's just stupid dude does he
always fight at ellis he always fights
and he does stupid [ __ ] he'll fight like
10 fans in a row or he'll fight like a
like a professional ufc fighter and then
well he's good at fighting is that good
yeah he's good he's like um like a
journeyman amateur who like sort of like
got really
dude ella's story is crazy he's a
skateboarder he started doing radio then
started racing cars and doing mma so um
i look at like i'm very similar in that
sense that like i like to just sort of
like put myself out there do things that
you know take me out of my comfort zone
and um i fought at his event another
comedian a few years ago before the
pandemic and i had my first amateur mma
fight
his name was ryan o'neal and i i kicked
his [ __ ] ass it was great it was the
best feeling ever he had a black belt in
taekwondo oh man i [ __ ] yeah let me
not be disparaging of alice i love ellis
too yeah of course dear friend of mine
great and uh if he wants to fight that's
great i mean i was just talking to mike
tyson about how like it's uh
it's awful for people to fight in their
50s but tyson is the one guy who got
away with it yeah and got nothing but
praise and money and
yeah i mean i think at the like the
higher level you know i think he wants
to have one more fight he knows it'll be
fun because we both have very passionate
audiences that are going to come out and
[ __ ] you know go crazy for it um and
i want to see if i could fight if i i
want to see if i can beat a guy who's
got a professional who has a
professional mma career winning record
2-0 um and if i can i can the worst case
scenario for me is i get in great shape
i [ __ ] learned to defend myself i
would have never had a blue belt had
i not gotten into this stupid [ __ ] now
like dude but i used to think i was
tough dude when i was 20 years old i had
no idea how to fight i didn't know how
to stand you know i had no idea and i
really thought it was tough i would
fight anybody in the world that got in
my face at a bar fight whatever it is
and now that i've trained a little bit
i'm such a [ __ ] because now i know how
little i know compared to what people
really know it's like it's a mind [ __ ]
dude the more i i'm so much more
prepared now but i'm so much more
terrified of the average human being but
i remember a long time ago you fought
michael bisping right right where we
sparred
but i saw the footage of that a long
time ago um
how close did you come i mean how good
is bisping compared to the rest of the
world did you even come
it's a silly question but like it's
let me tell you something dude it's
actually not a silly question but
because you could probably kick both of
our asses same time no way maybe i think
dude
pulls his pants down puts his ass on my
face and i can freak out you grab my
legs it's over dude but maybe like
maybe but i'm saying like then you go
and fight somebody like bisping like
there's not a chance in hell yeah let me
tell you something about you know this
is any ufc level fighter because i've
sparred and trained with a decent amount
of them at this point because i got a
lot of friends that work in the business
michael bisping in particular
is
just
it is such a difference in terms of
level it is it's
it's people don't really understand i
think people see it in a cage fight and
go like oh i've gone to bar fight i can
move around a little bit
i mean the level is crazy i when i the
first time i i grappled with bisping
i i questioned who i was as a man like
the next time i [ __ ] my girlfriend i
couldn't get hard like i i had to get in
the mirror i had to like [ __ ] you
know i had to talk myself up afterwards
to just regain any sense of [ __ ]
manhood because to know that
a man out there could just take me in
front of my child and make me suck my
own dick he could [ __ ] smack me in
the face he could go dude he could do it
you take my girlfriend home what am i
gonna do there's nothing i can do and
it's humbling it was the most humbling
experience in my entire life but the
level in terms and there's guys that are
in the gym that are like good there's
like there's like black belts and brown
belts and jujitsu and guys that have
been doing muay thai that are really
really really good and then you guys
that go to the ufc
it's we're talking about a whole other
level of it's not only just the talent
and being good at fighting but the level
of athleticism when they train and they
spar they're fighting with the absolute
best and the intensity that they do it
with there's just no keeping up with it
it was absolutely crazy bisping doesn't
even like me right now but i gotta say
dude the man's a [ __ ] beast he's a
monster he really is
i uh
well well i will have to find out what
what
that was about but back to this jason
ellis fight
let me
just put put it in another perspective
i uh
reacted to
justin bieber challenging tom cruise to
a fight in the octagon this happened in
2019 i immediately
piled into my van
with scott and we drove out to vegas to
uh
speak with dana white on camera
i said
dana i think uh tom cruise is afraid of
justin bieber but i am not
and i want you to set up a fight between
me and justin bieber in the octagon i
was so proud
of uh of just what a ridiculous thing
getting dana white on camera like it was
just it felt to me like this great coup
yeah and then
johnny knoxville says
you've got yourself in kind of a
lose-lose situation here oh
you know either
you uh
you know you get beat up
by justin bieber or
you beat up justin bieber
like either wins it's a it's a loss no
it's a win-win it's hilarious if you get
beat up but it's [ __ ] hilarious right
if justin bieber wipes the floor with
you in front of your family and friends
there's not a funnier thing on the
planet
and
that'll be the closing video of your
show as justin bieber be as you scream
and cry
that's very true and that's precisely
what would happen because justin bieber
is in phenomenal shape he's trying
trains with floyd mayweather yeah so
yeah if he trains yeah you can't just
jump in you really can't jump into it if
against a guy who translates i've been
training for a little while now and
people think i'm crazy for going in with
jason ellis who's been training probably
for a decade i mean the cardio to go two
rounds is [ __ ] incredible you know
it's gnarly it's it's gnarly um and uh
when's the last time you were in a
street fight
dude like i i've never been in a street
fight there's been um
there there were a couple times that i
was able to wrestle my way out of a
street fight like where i realized oh my
god like this guy is you know punching
me i just managed to duck it yeah and
like once i've ducked the punch i see
that like the more they hear his near
his legs you know
he's like right here so i could just
grab his legs and then like sort of uh
hope that somebody breaks it up and then
what happened i mean i think i've
actually successfully dug to punch did a
double leg and then just held a guy and
just be like okay we're not gonna fight
and the guy i've got the guy you know so
you won wrapped up yes i won
points
right
like uh you got the decision i remember
that happening once
i've been sucker punched a couple times
and not punched back wow
i just i'm not like i'm not like that
not a violent dude but my uh my pitch to
dana white for
for the justin bieber
i said i
i think this is an exciting fight
because i know justin bieber can throw a
punch
and i know i can take a punch yeah oh
for sure
well that's the problem is bieber's not
strong enough to actually knock you out
so it's just him beating you up for a
really long time yeah yeah yeah for sure
but in in any case i i would be slightly
concerned and again nothing but love and
respect to ellis but if if you
if you win
you beat up a 50 year old yeah and and
if you lose you got beat up by 50. so
like i mean i and whatever dude i'm just
being worse i'm being a hater and that's
[ __ ] you should by all means do it
you both have the the the fan base
it's rabid and i love that you've got
both the
the fighting audience and the comedy
audience
which which begs the question what is
the bigger
performing podcast that believe you me
with michael bisping or the legion of
skanks so i left believing me a little
while ago oh shoot i wasn't even aware
of that no no it's okay no don't worry
about it and they're crushing it um
anthony smith is now on the show who's
uh uh okay title challenger oh and then
he's very articulate
he's super likeable the [ __ ] man dude
honestly he's great and the show is
great it's still on my network i run a
podcast network called gas digital um
and um their show is is massive their
show is massive legion of skanks is my
other show also massive those are the
two biggest shows on the network and
they're sort of neck and neck we we sort
of go back and forth um am i the common
denominator i don't know but you know
some would say that well presumably
we'll find out soon enough point go to
podcasting that's what they say um but
uh the point of podcast the my audience
and it has been for a long time and the
mma audience is incredible and i do
another mma show called yoma may rap
with my buddy dave smith who's the i'm
legion of skanks as well okay um
you know but the comedy audience is what
i'm i'm passionate about it's what i
really know i'm a dummy dude i don't
really know that much about fighting
like i i
i fell into it i i was hired at siriusxm
to like just be like kind of comic
relief on an mma show right and then
they're like oh we got michael bisping
coming in to try to do a radio show do
you want to test with him and then i did
and i remember the joke that got him the
joke that made him want to work with me
um he goes uh he goes
he goes i got in trouble for uh on i was
doing a a fox broadcast and i said the
guy was on queer street and it's like
you can't say that you can't say
christian i was like it's not like he
said he was on boulevard
he's gotta crack it up dude and that was
that we went to break and he was like
all right this is the guy so and then we
did the radio show for a long time we
ended up doing the podcast for a long
time and people grow apart we we're
doing a different thing you know he's
dude he's super [ __ ] i mean he's
massive he's one of the biggest
commentators in the ufc yeah i mean he's
he's
[ __ ] brilliant
dude he's literally
one of the best analysts there are and
understands the fight game on a whole
other level you know what a journey of a
career so i just don't have anything bad
to say about the guy even though i meet
him with butt heads on uncertain things
sure i mean you just said before it's
not a bad thing about him but he said
bisping doesn't even like me right now
like why would like i can't qualify that
statement i'll qualify it we we ended up
ending the podcast not in the best terms
um over something that had nothing to do
with the podcast we just really saw
things very very differently and behind
the scenes just bumped heads and said
things that shouldn't have been said and
then it just sort of blew up into
something that it shouldn't have
honestly i i literally i wish him the
best i obviously like have a ton of
respect for him and knowing him in a
very personal way i'd like to think that
one day we'll be friends again we'll you
know it remains to be seen man are you
over here torching my bridge
he still does a podcast on my network
our producers so you know work with him
and um he's killing it dude like you
know i um yeah i really like bisping a
lot you know and it's something he
doesn't like i don't know that he thinks
about me that much right now
right i saw i was on a flight to hawaii
recently the most stupid thing that that
i've done in years i'm actually about to
take my son to hawaii
yeah we went on a vacation he hates
vacations you hate vacations i have a
vacation it was my girl's birthday and
she like makes a big deal out of
birthdays i can't stand birthdays so
annoying hopefully she doesn't listen to
this podcast but isn't that the most
annoying thing in the world it's pretty
it's pretty annoying yeah it's your
[ __ ] birthday you've had 30 of them
who gives a [ __ ] right and and
never mind the fact that this birthday
has now made me a whole [ __ ] year
older yeah you know which i'm not
particularly interested in and
my phone which is already like just
uh you know a nuisance on the easiest
day is now going bang bang bang all day
with people i don't even want to hear
from yeah yeah you know
you gotta thank everybody how annoying
it is everyone's just yeah can i just
stop answering the text thumbs up
i don't even do that i just put my phone
down i don't even look at it and then
holidays and birthdays can't stand up
here too much but but you know i do love
my girls so i wanted to uh do something
special like i hate airports
you know i say said
you know but she loves travel
i'm like babe for your birthday i want
to do something special i'm going to put
myself through an airport to show you
how much i love you wow let's go to
hawaii and we get to hawaii it's pouring
tortured yourself pouring rain the whole
time and i'm like
i'm like objectively like what are we
doing here we're accomplishing nothing
we're wasting time i i i came to realize
that relaxing stresses me out wow well
we got back on the plane to go home and
he's like why did we do this i'm like
bro we got to hit the reset button every
now and again he's like my reset button
is on tour in the bus and that's my
happy place and i never want to take a
vacation again for the rest of my life i
can't wait to get back on my bike i'm
the same way by the time the last day of
vacation i i
am craving work craving to go home back
to whatever i'm doing i i've always i
have a million things going on a million
irons in the fire and i start to but i
also can spend three or four days and
that's my max i go to jamaica like twice
a year i love jamaica i'm i'm like big
ten pothead big time pod head love
reggae music
where do you go in jamaica i usually go
to ocho rios i went to villa with i
bring my family we brought my company we
brought like 18 of our producers and we
had a whole little retreat this is
impressive dude
a podcast network yeah yeah and what's
it called again gas digital so yeah gas
digital stands for gomez and sutton so
sutton is my business partner have you
ever done the sdr show with big jack
his partner his his co-host ralph sutton
the big you know lurch looking guy yeah
he's the other owner of gas digital i've
definitely done that podcast yeah uh i
feel like uh i
i can't remember what like uh
salacious [ __ ] talking i did on that one
but sure i remember big j i'll draw it
out of you because big j so likable and
sweet but he's one of the filthiest
dirtiest minds in the world so you're
talking to him and then all of a sudden
you realize you're in a conversation
that's going to probably get you can't
nobody
it's not it's not that it's just that i
think what it was it was in the white
hot peak of the the metoo stuff and uh
like i i seem to recall that i was just
like man that maybe i said like i'm
ashamed to be an la comic or something
you know it was just like doors slamming
and and uh i just felt that like
with with certain
comedians getting uh you know tangled up
in in scandals and just watching like
their whole like inner circle just
they don't get no loyalty at all dude i
mean it was pretty gnarly it's crazy
that's sort of the you know whatever i'm
not gonna trash there's a lot of great
comics from l.a you know but that that
big there's a big group that just sort
of like the [ __ ] hit the fan and then
they were like cool see you later
i mean it was the extra part was
everybody coming out with their official
public statements about how oh i never
went on tour with that i wasn't even i
don't even know that crazy like crazy
where it's like damn dude please it's
just like if i i mean
i'm i'm loyal like a dog you could show
me
big j murdering somebody behind a
wendy's and i'm like dude it's not him
sorry
and behind closers dude why would you do
that
think about the podcast what is wrong
with you right right now
speaking of big j and fighting and
comedy it all comes together when big j
gets [ __ ] yanked off the stage
you were there for that i tried to
protect him wow hopefully luis gomez
doesn't try to protect me sheesh
but i'll tell you one thing i'm not
trying to protect i'm doing it is my
health by using athletic greens every
day this is the comprehensive
convenient daily nutrition which happens
to be absolutely delicious pour it into
your water in the morning and
it's got 75 different vitamins
minerals whole food-sourced superfoods
and probiotics and adaptogens telling
you man this is the secret to filling in
the gaps in your crappy diet
i love it it's delicious and it helps me
think better too you notice how sharp i
am these days i attribute that to
athletic greens and my love affair with
them plus they love you the listeners of
the wild ride podcast so they're willing
to give you five
of these if you're a first time customer
five
daily packets and an entire year's
supply of immune
boosting vitamin d you can't beat it
dude to get this deal you go to
athleticgreens.com
stevo
and hurry up because i think some of you
might have pretty bad diets and need
this stuff badly so one more time go to
athleticgreens.com
devo for five free packs and a year's
supply of immune boosting vitamin d
now let's hear about this disaster on
stage
did you miss the kick i did miss the
kick did i
he tells a story in his act now it's
going to be in his uh special he's
recording uh his special at skank fest
which you'll be at yeah epic um and uh
so you know he's trashing this girl this
girl's being an [ __ ] the whole show
and he starts trashing her big j is a
master of crowd work there's literally
nobody better in the world than crowd
work like he's literally
um and you know
you know if if somebody's getting upset
during like crowd work it just gets
funnier for everybody around them so
it's like contagious so now everyone is
like she's upset and everyone's just
pointing and laughing at her i mean i
get from her perspective it's mortifying
i mean she's [ __ ] she's drunk and
pissed he's never particularly mean no
he's not he's letting very often you
just sort of let them talk themselves
into it you don't really need to say
much people
josh wolfe was saying he'll let the girl
or the guy there's a girl 99.99 he'll
make sure that everybody in the crowd
hates her so that he can just go in as
hard as you can on her and everybody
loves it yeah you got to wait until the
crowd gets a little bit annoyed you have
to let them sort of bury themselves
because they're going to they're not
professional comedians they don't know
how to speak publicly it's it's unfair
it's and they don't have a microphone
the whole thing is trying to grapple
with
[Laughter]
the girl's brother was there he's a big
[ __ ] dude
and he starts making a beeline toward
the stage of the stage was like a five
foot high it's like a concert yeah dude
and the guy
grabs big j by his ankles because big j
assume the guy's going to get up on the
stage i mean the footage is horrifying
he would assume that he was like badly
badly
luckily the guy pulled him jay landed on
top of the guy and squashed the guy oh
nice and then uh you know we didn't do
anything to him obviously physically we
would never do anything to him nor would
the fans but that guy walked away for
some reason he was bruised and his eyes
was like all right he said somebody
maced him it was weird i have no idea
what happened but our fans they
they were right there and they they they
were ready to have some words with the
guy
what was more uh
but anyway when he grabbed him though i
saw it happening and i ran out i'm just
a fat oaf and i have no coordination so
i tried to kick the guy but i missed
and then jacob pulled off the stage so
what was more embarrassing uh trying to
defend
jay in that situation or grappling
michael bisping oh uh
grappling michael bisping oh jesus
christ jesus christ he made you suck
your own dick
to completion
which is particularly hard i mean is uh
is is grappling the word for them you
were sparring well i've done both i've
i've done
and he's not even known for grappling in
the ufc but he's like dude it's wild
it's [ __ ] wild it was i remember the
whole point of uh saying about that i
went to hawaii was that while i was on
the flight out to hawaii
on the american airlines video on demand
the free in-flight entertainment here's
this unbelievable uh bisping documentary
made by universal yeah it's like i was
like wow when it started with the
universal logo i was like man this is
like was it in theaters and [ __ ] i don't
know i'm not sure either way that was
the most badass documentary i had to
text him i was like dude you just made a
flight to hawaii like so i hate flying
and you just made the flight such a
treat bravo for this yeah and he said i
wish i was on a flight to
hawaii like i don't get it you're like
dude how do you hate fun what's wrong
with that
i worked over there did you not work in
hawaii i worked like every morning i was
supposed to go to key west this past
weekend we went to key west where i'm
covered in bug bites because no seems
ate me alive dude oh my god
no seams have you ever heard of them no
they're little tiny mosquitoes you can't
[ __ ] say they're like they're called
biting midges scabies dude i have
scabies
that'll get that'll get us in trouble
maybe yeah i'm sorry little person
mosquito and yeah i personally think
little person is way more way more
offensive yeah condescending it's so
condescending yeah it's like [ __ ] for
black people it's awful you can't say
that
i don't know that
it's really i'm saying it's offensive i
agree with you
we agree that's what i'm saying but the
difference here is that little person is
deemed the appropriate political correct
thing to say [ __ ] up i know yeah that
that that filth that just came out of
your mouth was never never well that's
what i'm saying that's what it would be
like if they did sanction that all right
and that would be a bad thing we've
we've now cleared the air so uh i was in
key west though we were supposed to take
a little like work trip so because we're
playing at skank fest meet a couple of
the producers where is it again it's
gonna be in vegas vegas
and i know that we're not supposed to
announce that i'm on it but i did i did
with big j yeah and i'm doing it with
you i love you guys until we were sold
out i think we went but we sold that in
like four minutes
what can somebody expect at a at a
legion of skanks so skankfest is like um
it's sort of like the gathering of the
juggalos except with stand-up comedians
yeah yeah kind of like that's a great
way to play it that's a great elevator
pitch for it so you've obviously talked
to somebody about this before
dude check out my hatchet man tattoo oh
hell yeah dude okay so you'll love it
i'm down with the clown you'll be
[ __ ] down it's a so our audience um
the best we describe it it's a party
it's you know festival's a weird way to
put it because you go to a comedy
festival it's at a bunch of different
venues it's one big venue a few thousand
people that are going in there's like
four or five stages that'll be going on
simultaneously within the venue sure
common areas it's super counter culturey
every everyone's just having a great
time partying there's always something
going on whether it's stand-up comedy
live podcast music we have a bunch of
musical acts um
yeah there's lots of arrests lots of
stds transporters there's uh
plenty of drugs yes there's like um yeah
all those like a fire fest but well yeah
it's not like a comedy festival because
comedy festivals do have all different
venues all over town yeah but it's very
much like a concert festival and that
there's one one venue just with many
different stories we got the idea or uh
basically the idea was from i did a few
cruises right have you ever done like uh
i used to be a clown on cruise ships
okay so national clown you know then all
right now if you've seen theme cruises
i'm sure it's like you know i did a
thing called um shiprocked where it was
a bunch of heavy metal bands and then
they had like a comedy stage right it's
crazy the bands that have cruises like
the 311 crews
uh the uh the barenaked ladies have a
cruise that's huge apparently their
radio
oh yeah yeah we did we did a podcast
together and we just we just didn't i
don't know who he was he didn't know who
i was and it was just we did not like
each other and now i love the guy he's
the best man like we always make a point
to get together for uh for for a dinner
or lunch yeah and uh and then afterwards
we we kind of grade on on how awkward it
was
like
you know you just sit down it's like
what what are we doing here
you hate fun stevo hates fun guys
i should be on my tour bus right now
working
right when we're eating breakfast yeah
but
we're always like this should be awkward
and it was surprisingly not that awkward
like we're both right i got uh matching
tattoos with mike carlton oh nice we got
the uh which elbow is it on yeah right
here
the
the grinder app logo
me and big j have a few matching tattoos
we have so dave smith is the other guy
that does our podcast with us so we both
have half hearts and mine says smith and
his says dave because they will give me
tattoos he's like a you know born and
raised brooklyn jew so you like whatever
you're not even like we tried to get him
to get like a dot tattoo yeah
jesus had tattoos dude yeah that as well
jesus had tattoos that was offensive
actually jesus christ
really
really did i dare you
um
but we took the influence because you go
on a cruise
you know on one deck there's a show
going on half an hour later another show
starts on another deck there's a meet
and greet over here and another deck but
the thing is you can't escape it like
everyone's eating together all the bands
all the comedians all the audience
they're all partying the whole time you
can't really escape them the bands don't
have their own private they have a deck
but honestly it's not really fun to hang
out on that deck nobody's there so like
when i did the impractical joker's crews
all the impractical jokers were hanging
out amongst the fans dude how huge are
those dudes it's crazy it's crazy it's
so weird just even to know my friends
are famous because comics grow up we're
like we're all eating [ __ ] we're all
poor until one day when we're not poor
and then it's not even like we're making
we're not rich like i make good money
for like uh like a high-end car salesman
you know those guys that are [ __ ]
selling lexuses and mercedes-benz that
might actually be doing better than me
right now that's where i'm at but all of
my friends like it's very weird to watch
them get famous right so
you you came up like early career with
the impractical jokers before they had
that show no i came up with a lot of
comics though and sal has been a friend
of mine for a long time sal was they
were already pretty big when when i
became friends with sal but it's
interesting to what he has that attitude
those guys were just dudes that worked
at a bar that were doing like improv
[ __ ] and they don't have sort of like
the ego of like i think a lot of guys
that get famous you go through the
audition process and you're acting and
you sort of get built a tough skin and
you're in hollywood you're you know it's
a different path with comedy it's sort
of like it's kind of cool to be poor i
think anybody who achieves like
big uh
success wealth fame whether it's comedy
whether it's acting with like no matter
what i think you can't
become famous without having some
growing pains oh you got to eat [ __ ] of
course yeah like you you turn into an
[ __ ] you get
bestowed all this like
you know
power and influence and you're gonna
abuse it and i'm just glad that that in
my case that was [ __ ] 20 years ago it
was no social media before everybody had
a video camera in their pockets
yeah and i'm extra lucky because now
i've been clean and sober for 14 years
and yeah and 14 years ago not everybody
had a
camera in their pocket so
i'm real lucky i know what it's like oh
yeah it's [ __ ] crazy but we were it
was just sort of like that we also were
in comedy i don't know if they
romanticize it the same way in acting
like just sort of grinding and being a
poor comic and [ __ ] sleeping on
somebody's couch like it's part of like
it's part of like
you sort of love it in a weird way like
you're just kind of getting up every
night you're going to open mics you're
trying to get laughter and [ __ ]
that's the the currency is just like
getting up on stage and like that's all
you sort of need i don't know if it's
as room and i've acted i've taken acting
classes i've done a ton of auditions it
just was never maybe for me anyway i
never sort of like that grind didn't
feel the same sort of romance and sort
of like
yeah what's your take on the difference
between east coast and west coast comedy
and by west coast comedy i mean austin
comedy
akash from flagrant said that yesterday
that's hilarious pretty funny but yeah
yeah i mean i think that uh yeah those
guys are
there's really no difference because
everyone nobody's from new york or l.a
right so everyone's from boston or
philly or all the best guys that are now
in new york or from philly or from
[ __ ] you know some other town all the
best guys in la you know were born and
bred in boston or new york i think um
you know in new york you everyone's
trying to grind nobody nobody really
gives a [ __ ] about like status in new
york whereas i think in la it's just a
little bit more well i mean if you can
get you have to have status to get a
spot at the seller right isn't it
status not as much stat so so that's a
great example so in new york to get a
spot at the salary if you're really
funny and you're poor and you have no tv
credits and you're just starting out you
can get into the seller you can when i
got into the seller i wasn't [ __ ] i had
nothing going on they just you know they
need honestly my story of getting the
seller was crazy was when tracy morgan
got into that crazy bus accident damn
the he had a couple comics on the bus
with him that were seller comics artie
fuqua
harris stanton as well and they both got
massively injured already was really
[ __ ] up over it right um and uh aria
was like the regular host at the comedy
cellar like the the dude you might know
if you've been to the seller he's a tall
black guy really handsome very
charismatic did he uh
get like obnoxiously wealthy out of that
i'm actually well he's dude different
[ __ ] fitted suit every day now
i would take that in a heartbeat are you
kidding me wow but he was the house host
at the seller like i'm talking about
five six nights a week he was the guy
when he got in that car accident they
were just like they were at a loss they
didn't have any hosts so they literally
put they booked me i didn't even
audition they i was hanging out with
bobby kelly and a couple other comics
and uh they were like oh louis is a
great host and then they were like dude
start working and they put me in right
there um and i had nothing going on so
it was based off of i mean do i think
walmart every day of my life
every day of my life we're really
starting the correct trajectory of my
career
that that's epic man
i see you said that you um
like refuse to audition for for tv or
anything anymore yeah not anymore yeah i
i
because
the brand of comedy that i do you know
we when the legion of skanks we call it
the most defensive podcast on earth and
we do that on purpose it's very much on
purpose if you click on it [ __ ] you you
knew what you were getting into we're
not tricking you we're not we're not
jumping you know i'm not jumping into
your tv screen and going hey you know i
i do a mild version of my comedy when i
come on this show i'm not doing this
[ __ ] that we do on legion of skanks
because i'm a guest here and that's not
what people are here for people are here
to listen to your brand of your comedy
and then the interview that you want to
have right so i have a very soon so
you're withholding can you don't walk in
get
give us a little sniff i threw dorothy
i threw [ __ ] out there you guys almost
[ __ ] had a heart attack
you don't want my brain
i saw you guys [ __ ] hit the edit
[ __ ] like
not me
no no no i'm kidding but yeah so but my
philosophy is like
um you have to come in and see what we
do we have a platform we have the
premium service so the the versions that
go out on itunes and on youtube they're
edited that we bleep out certain words
we you know we edit them down that is a
specific version if you have to come to
my platform to get it unscientified okay
so so you've got a subscription yeah i
got a subscription um through gas
digital network dot com and you can get
all the and we have you know 700
episodes of the podcast that are not
available anywhere else so it's only the
latest 20 of them are available on
itunes and on youtube now with like with
the this podcast that we're doing right
now is not with the network
it's completely independent we just have
let's talk we well we just have a uh a
guy who buys the ads you know and he's
uh particularly
savvy he's a great friend of mine great
he um
he's only got like three or four
podcasts so we get like
genuine attend it's like a boutique
operation you get a lot of attention
from him and i just don't understand
outside of the actual
uh shopping or selling of uh the ad
spots yeah why like what
does the network do
what does a podcast network do well i'll
tell you what i don't need one i'm not
with the podcast network and all i [ __ ]
one more time three
two
one
i'll tell you what i know about podcast
networks is that i'm not with one
because i don't need one you know what i
need
i need ship station because i like to
sell a ton of merch and what is
shipstation it's a platform that gives
me the best rates for all of the
shipping
ways to go fedex
ups
usps that's right and it's one clean and
simple interface which brings them all
together in easy to use way and i'm
telling you not only am i using ship
station but i'm going after full send
yeah you heard me what do they send
nothing yeah so my brand yeah dude
that's what we're talking about and how
am i gonna try and sell a ton of yeah
dude merch well first off by telling you
to pre-order this right now and second
by using shipstation and no matter what
your business is or how you sell if
you've got amazon just your own website
etsy doesn't matter it brings them all
into this one easy to use interface and
gives you
prices for shipping that are usually
saved for fortune 500 companies i'm
telling you it's the secret to my
success and they're willing to give you
a 60-day free trial you just go to
shipstation.com
at the top right corner you click the
microphone you use the promo code stevo
and you've got hassle free totally free
easy
shipping service at your fingertips for
60 days you try that out for free and
tell me you you're not making money yeah
dude because that's what it's all about
is making money so one more time go to
shipstation.com
hit the microphone in the top right
corner use the promo code stevo and
enjoy 60 days of hassle-free free ship
station make ship happen yeah dude now
let's find out about this goofball's
network
so for certain people they don't need it
right certain people like tim dillon was
on my network and when he left my
network he blew the [ __ ] up right um
but you know it wasn't right for him he
wanted to do his patreon thing he wanted
to go out there and you know do it
independently is it production help like
production helps you get there we have
studios uh downtown they're gonna edit
for you don't have to hire an editor two
producers social media manager post
production guy all the clips get edited
for you they get captioned we have the
actual studio space itself we have a
beautiful studio downtown booking
booking of guests we
also have 18 producers on staff so we
have meetings every single week we have
two meetings a week they have a creative
meeting and then we have like sort of a
meat and potatoes number meeting so
we're sharing data what works for this
podcast what's not working for this
podcast the new algorithms new you know
platforms when you know youtube is
launching is launching their new version
of of tick tock and reels and when you
know reels launch just sort of
understanding the landscape when you
have a collective mindset which the goal
is to grow everyone's brand and make
everyone more money there's massive
benefit that is outweighs the 20 or
whatever that we're going to take of the
the profits of the show okay now when um
you
don't give me talking business stevo
when you do a a contract with with a
podcaster to get them into your network
the contract would have to
address uh adsense revenue from the
youtube channels and what would be the
split on that just as an example so
if you're on your personal youtube
channel we don't take any of the youtube
revenue they take none of that we we
have we sell our own ads we actually
have our own ad sales company separately
from
uh gas digital so we sell our own ads um
and we make money off of subscriptions
and we make money off we have our own
merch company as well called
podcastmarch.com and where do you do the
fulfillment for the merch
so no we were but it was a [ __ ]
nightmare it was we were we're like we
got this we could just part-time do do
the no it got crazy so we have a partner
that does fulfillment here in new york
city um and that's a whole other [ __ ]
business yeah
does the merch
do you
establish an inventory and then sell it
down or do you print the shirts after
they've been over we do both so
depending on the really popular designs
we establish inventory we do print on
demand for certain designs which is more
expensive process or very often we do
like pre-sales so we'll do like for this
month you can get the shirt limited
edition once a month is over that's that
and then it ships out after how long
does it take you to turn around the
pre-sale like okay we got 100 orders
two to four weeks so so but after the
pre-sale's done so let's say we do a
two-week pre-sale right then you're
gonna only print as many as you saw so
there's no that's the best margins
possible that's that's how to you know
that's how we make the most money off of
and there's also limited edition so you
say this shirt's going away you'll never
get it again right i mean dude the bad
friends guys bobby and andrew yeah they
kill it i'm sure they they're destroying
with pre-orders mm-hmm yeah pre-orders
yeah
told me some of the numbers and i was
just like what the [ __ ] yeah you got a
cool merch too regional skanks like our
logo is so [ __ ] sick it's just like
that logo it works we have to think we
do scan cans so it looks like a logo
yeah i mean it's [ __ ] it's not not
entirely unlike the grinder app logo
there's a lot of notes like the grumpy
coffee logo
i think there's a corn album that has
something like that on it yeah
we're hacks we're major we're hacks from
the 90s though big j opened for corn i
know he loves he tells everyone and uh
john and everyone else here's that and
go yeah dude that's that's [ __ ] gay
but when big j he [ __ ] he loves he
gets a tear in his eye every time he
watches it and and we we spoke with
jonathan davis the lead singer of course
he just gushes about big oh he does oh
dude absolutely so check this out we did
a thing called the the presidential
election on legion of skanks during the
pandemic it got crazy right and we were
like we're gonna make a president of
legion of skanks you know the old hack
radio bit right
and me dave and jay were running and
then ari shafir jumped into the mix do
you know ari
of course he's the [ __ ] man or he's
ori is one of the sweetest people in
comedy one of the funniest people in the
world and he just get he brings the best
out of us he's a prankster and he's just
got to like uh there's just something
about him dude this whole this whole we
had a is hari should fear the definition
of they can't cancel you if you don't
give a [ __ ] yes okay
we give our sphere a lie detector test
on the shell like a fbi grade lie
detector test and we asked him if he
regretted the kobe tweet and he said no
and he was not lying
he did not regret it at all i mean that
was like and then the the we also asked
him if he found brendan trump funny and
he said yes and that was a lie
okay i doubt that i saw
him
but they were all
did you ask him that no but he during
this election is when he dosed big j oh
he did it after he dosed big j with acid
it was [ __ ] nuts dude well all right
you know here's what really happened i
tried to dose already right right and he
knew it was happening so he switched his
drink but i just had somebody i told
shane gillis like an idiot i told shane
gillis i was like dude i'm gonna do it i
was like all right he's gonna win the
election today this whole thing is
stupid okay like ori's gonna come in and
become the president of legionnaires
he's not even on the show i was like i'm
going to dose him though to get back for
bert oh yeah i put a tab of acid
in his beer one type of asthma or
anything like that you put the piece of
paper in there a drop a piece of paper
okay piece of paper in there right that
doesn't seem like it would be
particularly effective i don't think it
would be that effective either to be
honest with you like if you've done acid
before you know but
he finds out so you see that it's all on
camera you it's you watch the whole
thing happen right at one point big j
makes it make the audience laugh he's
kind of eating it out because we have a
whole live crowd out there jay's in on
it he he he thinks that r is getting
dosed he thinks ori's being judged but
doesn't know that i already switched
their drinks so ari leans over switches
the drinks you see shane like oh [ __ ]
and it's just it's on camera when you
watch it back it's wild it's a wild
thing and big j sure enough he drinks
the whole thing dude and then ari starts
acting like he's on acid right and so
i'm like i'm like yeah i [ __ ] got him
so i get really into right at the end of
the show like already like you're doing
all this he's acting so i'm like i was
like that's it all right i got you i
don't shoot and then he comes out of it
he goes you think you got me he's like
you think i [ __ ]
knew you were gonna do that he was like
when you weren't looking i switched your
drinks and then big j realize it you see
big jay's face she's like dude i don't
feel right right now
stayed up for 48 hours straight
48 hours straight couldn't tell me about
it didn't trip he just just mad at his
friends so the only effect of the acid
was the negative thought like that when
you have a bad trip i don't know how
much after you've done it
yeah dude so when you have a bad trip
and you have that negative [ __ ] thing
and you can't shake it that was him for
48 hours he hated his friends he
wouldn't answer anybody's calls is it
safe to say that in the world of legion
of skanks two wrongs do make a right
look at me it created one of the
funniest moments in podcasting big j is
still salty about it to this day where
can they see this video it's up on the
youtube channel if you look up
legislation
what i would do is i would go watch it
on gas digital network dot com subscribe
to the premium service use the promo
code los get a free trial you can go
watch the entire um series that we did
of the election when it starts right up
until the end and it was we did a trial
afterwards on whether or not who's more
responsible for jay's dosing me or ari
it was a really fun
it's a fun show dude it's so silly we
say we say all the dumb words you're not
supposed to say right
now like i got to believe that on
youtube that that's a very very strike
worthy no we bleep everything out yeah i
know but just the like showing
drugs like and
showing someone being
i mean that's that dude that's high
level on the joey diaz podcast they were
[ __ ] frying balls on the ari was on
it i know but
at the very least that's consensual when
you're giving someone
drug we're dosing someone without their
consent that's the highest level of us i
think if big j would have complained
about it anyway yeah we probably could
have gotten our channel taken down and
gotten in trouble
but
the reality is like
it's it's cool
well it's a bit you know what i'm saying
what we really could say is like no what
are you talking about
yeah would you if i dose both of you at
the beginning of this podcast there's
just a thing that i do
that would be a tough one because we're
sober guys
i'd be pissed but i'd be like freelance
well you know what dude
for sure yeah i mean that i kind of
would too
let's get out of here dude
live
that's that's really like the rule for
sober people is you just ask yourself
what was your intention because there
was a time when uh i
went like i asked for her water
and uh the guy brought down it was it
was like a [ __ ] gin and tonic i have
no idea
take a sip but
did it [ __ ] do a little bit you know
it absolutely [ __ ] with me however
like i gen you know i mean you know in
your heart what your portions were like
that was an accident well so then the
the guy that uh this guy was driving an
uber and these girls left a little
altoid box and he when they got out he
he opened it up and he was sober he had
like four or five years he opened up the
box and then there was a bunch of dust
in there so he's like [ __ ] it and he
snorted it see that it was crazy it was
altoid dust
so is that a relapse
or what that's a relapse that's
psychologically a relapse that's light
but no that's not a relapse because the
drugs didn't i mean it was like so i
really but when you're talking about the
intent the intent was
he was like [ __ ] it
i guarantee that guy's not still sober
today for sure no [ __ ] way
fair point yeah but at that point it
wasn't a real life yeah not technically
i'll give him that five yeah in a court
of law it's not a relapse right
yeah that's heavy yeah
it's kind of like if you're in a
committed relationship and and you hit
on a woman and she rejects you you've
not cheated you tried oh you failed yeah
your girl will that will you're dead
i've gotten dude oh my god actually
speaking of which you said you had to go
to rehab for a sex addict yeah i've got
i need to know if i'm a sex addict
because i very well might be do you have
shame
in your life from sexually acting out
and shame is a big one but is it causing
problems in your life i mean that's the
definition of addiction is continued
behavior despite consequences
has it caused problems cheating has
caused problems in my life
that's what where's close problems i'm
not currently in a relationship i think
the level of sex addiction that i have
now which is i just i constantly need
sex
it's a time suck man yeah it's the most
[ __ ] well that's my favorite type of
sex being time sucked
so i [ __ ] love it dude
yes i mean like it's it's uh like
there's there's a lot of stress with
like man what did i just put my dick in
like oh yeah like with the health
concerns especially like scott's a
particularly
like problematic
type of sex ed because he's a germaphobe
i'm a contract but i hate condoms
i convince myself that i have aids daily
just a [ __ ] i'm dude i've made out
with hookers i've gone down on them it's
a goddamn nightmare okay i just wouldn't
say i'm profoundly grateful for my over
five years of sexual sobriety my dick's
not been anywhere it doesn't belong wow
for over five years i've lived
transparently and honestly in a
committed relationship that's great and
i want to be there by the way that's
what i want like now i'm getting a
little older dude i got a nine-year-old
kid yeah you're 40. as i approached 40 i
thought oh my god and i had a joke in my
stand-up back then i was like you know
i'm i'm
turning i'm approaching 40 and and i'm
asking myself like do i want to be in my
50s like
chasing [ __ ] around trying to hump
everything it was the most important
thing forever do i want to be 50
physically falling apart and trying to
[ __ ] everything that moves and no i
don't want to turn into paulie shore
yeah
who will also be at skank fest
i love him i i i love him but but that
was one of my jokes and when you talk
about that when you talk about the
the grind and the comedy club circuit
you know that when you're in that uh
comedy club
apartment like you're just sleeping in
paulie shores calm yeah
it's all over the way you get a blue
light dude
really any any comedy condo you're going
to sleep in some comedians come that you
don't want to be in right um but yeah i
mean look that like chasing [ __ ] and
like it was just
such an important whatever it was i
think it's because i just didn't get
[ __ ] when i was a kid and it's just
like when i was finally charismatic
enough and i sort of learned the game
like i'm a salesman so i started
applying like sales technique to like
like i just rejection's not bothering me
i get it you know it's a game of numbers
i'm like cool i can close one out of ten
girls so let me just [ __ ] ask 10
girls and i'll get laid right
i get it and it's so counter-intuitive
yeah that
that that
you're doing it to validate yourself to
to build your own self-worth because you
because you're telling yourself i'm a
guy who can get laid
but the reality of the behavior is just
accomplishing the dead opposite yeah
like the more
the more sex you're having the less
your self-worth actually becomes you
know like
you think you're validating yourself and
being the man but like it's just so
backwards yeah and like i think that for
me i really got to a point like as i
approached 40 i just thought dude like
this whole just trying to get laid all
the time just always trying to get your
dick sucked it's just such like
uh
just a one-way street to just a
miserable existence just being you know
and i don't want that and i really
subscribed to the idea that future
happiness and quality of life is
dependent on me learning how to be in a
healthy committed relationship and also
when you're trying to [ __ ] around with
that many chicks right so you're trying
to like it was almost a game like can i
get laid more more than once in a day
more than twice a day right like like it
was like like legit like that's where
it's like really bad behavior where then
you're now you're lying to multiple
people 100 and it was like [ __ ] boy
behavior like i was really liking like i
was acting like i liked these girls and
i was like you know just whatever what
it means to an end so that's why that
was sort of where the shame and the
guilt and the anxiety from being a
[ __ ] liar that's the thing that like
now in my life where i've really turned
a corner at 40 is i'm not lying to
people i won't lie to chicks i won't lie
to people my friends because it gives me
anxiety it's not even about being an
honest person i don't want to live with
that anxiety i would rather just deal
with the the sort of the minor
uncomfortability of having an honest
conversation because it's way more
comfortable than being but
it's even more than that it's like
sexualizing your feelings so if anything
that happens to you you sexualize it and
so what that means is like i i got back
into therapy and they're because i have
like severe intimacy issues with women
and so like i i kind of get
claustrophobic and i'm like really
trying to work on that
so they're they're like
you need to abstain 30 60 90 days
without having an orgasm
so i'm not he's on like day 6 i'm on the
juice i haven't had an orgasm in like 60
days
no no but what it does
431 days without blowing a load whoa i
did not blow a load for the entire year
that was for with that that was because
of the therapy and being able to have
that sex addict rehab yeah and so
i don't want to go to this place
but but what you'll notice come right
now exactly because you're getting
involved we're talking about i'm getting
all worked up let's go dude let's jerk
each other off yeah you don't have to do
that but i could say i could say i
absolutely relate to everything that
you're saying and and and the one thing
that you were describing about uh
you know
acting like you like
like girls in in in my case i would
actually feel genuinely infatuated about
about a girl i would believe that like i
really she was this special thing and i
would pour on the charm make her feel so
special that she was like just the one
and then and i would feel that way but
then once i hooked up with the chick
then i would like it would just be like
it would fade pretty quickly like a like
a light switch if the switch is flipped
and all of a sudden it was the game it
was the hunt yeah and it was it was in
in my inventory work as a guy in
recovery
we we just identified this behavior as
fully sociopathic yeah it was a
repeating pattern of misleading
the person yeah to believe that that i
really really that you know that i was
going to be the one for them
misleading and then exploiting and then
neglecting and then abandoning and then
repeat yeah you know and and like you
don't have to be freud to like to to
understand
that
really was going on i have terrible
abandonment issues fear of rejection is
the gnarliest thing so when i was
treating women this way
not only was i not treating them the way
i want to be treated i was specifically
treating them the way i most fear being
treated right which is the recipe for
like the worst most toxic terrible karma
you could you know you're going going
around treating people the way you most
fear being treated that's the opposite
of any [ __ ] rad
good did you have to not come for 461
days in order to come to that conclusion
no they just said you need to rewire
your brain he's just he's so extreme
that he just said [ __ ] it yeah they they
think they say
when you finally came
i mean was it
did i stole a joke from bobby lee but
like uh a marshmallow coming out
yeah how long were you supposed to go
for and why did you go 431 days they
recommended like 30 60 90 something like
that what is 30 60 90 just like that
like
you know something like that like to
take it take a pic you do 30 days not
blowing loads or 60 or 90 if you want
that's the extreme version is 90. yeah
and you're on day 60 right now i'm on
day 60 and and the the idea behind that
is like anything that happens to me
during the day i'm just like ugh i'm
going to go jerk off yeah oh i'm going
to go text girls like there's none of
that and you can see your brain actually
rewiring to different pathways of like
everything that i did would be
compulsively to just to go out my dick
yeah yeah but in a weird way that's like
isn't that how we got to the moon isn't
that why we're talking in the
microphones right now
they're you know that's very freudian
right everything is sexual everything
yeah but i wasn't i'm not happy with my
behavior right look i don't know if i'd
be sitting here today with the [ __ ]
great stevo if i did if i wasn't so
obsessed with getting [ __ ] because that
was a part of the reason that i stayed
out late that was a part of the reason
why i kept on getting up on stage i get
it i don't i don't regret i'm going back
on it now i was like you know what
30 60
i don't regret all my years of drug
addiction yeah you know like being that
wild out of control drug addict stevo
was like there was something there was a
mystique about it that that worked for
me of course until it didn't exactly
until it becomes destructive right right
and yeah i i've i have no regrets up
until i had my kid i'm like i'm i'm a
simpleton dude i believe in like you
know chaos theory like my my nut met
that egg anything that happened before
that moment he wouldn't be alive my kid
my kid is my [ __ ] world you know what
i'm saying so that's great i mean like i
think it's it's worth there's a lot of
value in regretting like doing harm you
know like
but to answer the question why i went
431 days in my mind and i think this is
really important like
i knew that
it would mean absolutely nothing for me
to find the right person
like i wasn't on a quest to find the
right person to get in a relationship
with i was on a quest to become the
right person
that would be worthwhile if somebody
worthwhile wanted to have a really great
my mantra was
i i'm working to become the man that the
love of my life deserves and and my
philosophy about that was that
i wanted to not only
remove myself to put distance between
myself and my history acting out
sexually but i also wanted to
prove to myself and to
my future love of my life that
i could go for like an insane amount of
time without giving in to the impulse to
giving into the urge you know like i i
just wanted to be able to trust myself
that i was i was
for 431 days i was being faithful to a
woman who i had not yet met how soon
into how long ago the relationship or
how long of the 461 days did you get you
31. so you waited 30 days i started i
started working with you around day 60
yeah yeah
i came in on as this professional [ __ ]
blogger
because because i was like man i just
got out of sex out of rehab and i don't
want to blow everything that i just
[ __ ] worked on i'm going to go on
tour and it's like i used to do meet and
greets with the entire entire audience
after every show and it was a bonafide
audition yeah you know like
and so i was like dude like that's why
we started to stop giving our secrets
yeah
the only uh the only way i could
expect to maintain my sexual sobriety
was to bring a sober companion so we
shared a room everywhere every every
[ __ ] night we slept next to each
other into twin beds
and to answer your question after that
how long was it until i met my girl i
had some misfires you know i had some
failed relationships yeah and uh you
know and i and i had to go back out but
you didn't hook up with any of the girls
like during that time you you would date
but you wouldn't hook up
um it's like they had a couple
relationships okay and uh and and they
you know for
they're the best i was capable of at the
time but but it was like third time was
a charm for relationships after
sexual sobriety what what happened that
day 431 that made you be like i'm gonna
do it today i was in austria all right
well no i remember clearly you sent me a
photo of the load all over your chest
but i'm saying like what
what uh
what made you decide to do it like okay
i think i can
come now
um
what it was was that i was filming this
this british reality television in
austria it was uh
a bonafide
six week vacation so i got paid a bunch
of money and the premise of the show was
uh winter sports we were at a ski resort
just skiing and luging and doing all
this fun [ __ ]
and and i wanted to uh
hook up with with one of the
you know
female contestants on the show and and i
really like like that for that six weeks
i was
just unplugged like back home in l.a i
had a weekly men's therapy group i had
like a support system
i just unplugged and and
by
on but you know by detaching from
everything that kept me accountable and
responsible and sober
just the the insanity took over and did
you look at it as like a [ __ ] up like
you failed or you were just like i'm
sort of ready to like i i went on to and
i was like okay i really i really care
about this woman she lives in england i
live in l.a she's got two kids
she's a wonderful person but it just
like didn't make sense you know you just
jerked off because you didn't want the
first time for you to do that to be
pretty much i was i was like okay now
she would have had three kids
i was
just
[ __ ]
yeah it would have been like a [ __ ]
genius
i i don't know that i think they
it arguably would be the other way
around no in the book autobiography of
yogi like yogananda's parents only
[ __ ] once a year to have a kid and
they're saying like the the semen
retention was able to like have a little
guru baby
oh wow that could be computers
yeah so in any case man it it's uh
it's it's it's a big deal and i think
that
with the sociopathic behavior of just
routinely harming doing harm to others
it's just not good well that that's
something i've tried to move past and
like honestly there's you know there's
there's there's the guilt of of uh you
know pulling the ghost routine pulling
out the rug and that that's harmful to
others there's the the the anxiety over
like health risks of acting out sexually
and that that exhibited the guilt the
the [ __ ] stress
and and then and then never even mind
the amount of the countless number of
hours just
squandered
on all this imagine when you take away
the the
the time suck just the wasted time
of chasing [ __ ] around yeah then you
get freed up
now all of a sudden you've got so much
time to focus your
energy imagine how successful you would
be your podcast network because if all
the time you squandered on chasing [ __ ]
around you put into focusing on uh
on your success i know i'd be a dork
yeah people wouldn't follow me then i
gotta be a leader
they like me because i'm a [ __ ] hand to
be honest with you how many how many
girls are you texting right now
honestly
in a weird way dude
like
i'm kind of really only talking to one
person
i mean i shouldn't say that because i
know really
four
no can i know because i kind of i
kind of like this one person right to
the point where i'm like
you know
i was dude i was supposed to [ __ ] i
kind of like this one person so the 16
others i'm texting mean nothing to me
all eight of these girls are gonna think
i'm talking about them right now
so if the girl that you really like says
like dude are you talking to anybody
else what do you say i would say yes i
would say yes but i the reality is like
i i've had plans recently with like
other chicks and i've kind of i've i've
canceled them because i'm kind of i got
this chick on my mind a little bit so
who knows i'm i'm i'm at a place now
where i i keep on jumping from
relationship to relationships that's the
other thing is i'll be in like i'll be
in a committed relationship to a check
until i get bored after six months and
then i start choosing six months is the
serial monogamous but six months is the
pattern at this point it's about six
months yeah that's my pattern where i i
go all right they're not going to be the
stepmother to my child they're not going
to be like the person
for that six months your your child has
now developed a relationship with them
and then you're uprooting it yeah yeah
and i try to be friends with them but
they'll hate me after we break up yeah
like in my mind i'm like why can't we be
friends i didn't do anything i bet i
didn't love you that much you want you
want to get your head [ __ ] up right
now or you no please i like you my head
[ __ ] up the so they have a thing
called your arousal template and your
arousal template is set when you're a
kid from like four to nine oh yeah as a
boy i was [ __ ] up my mom showed me
clockwork orange when i was seven so i i
knew what gang rape was when i was seven
like i watched those scenes they're
burned into my head i'll never forget
them
i was
i was eight years old
when
uh
someone showed me i spit on your grave
where the the girl said in the beginning
the girl gets gang raped and then she
goes hurt and she murders everyone who
raped her that's the whole movie yeah
yeah yeah that's the whole movie yeah
there's a scene where one of the guys
she's murdering the guy one of the guys
who gang raped her in the beginning and
she cuts off his his wiener and there's
a shot she throws in the sink you see
the wiener land in the sink
just immediately understood that she was
not having sex with this man out of
intimacy and i knew it was for money not
because i saw money there's an older guy
and like she yelled at me to get out of
the room and i remember just i remember
as a kid just being like oh yeah she's
being paid to do that and i have no idea
where i got that thought from it was
just a natural conclusion um yeah like
sexually like from those i want you i
want you to continue to the point
because i'm actually interested in this
but it's just sort of immediately when
you said that i feel like there's a lot
of [ __ ] up sexual things that like i
was experienced or as privy to during
those formative years that's [ __ ] me
up now well so that's why like
my takeaway from what you just said is
man that's why he's so [ __ ] funny
yeah
they [ __ ] me up but it made me funny
right that's the silver lining um but
it's like uh that's what you replicate
over and over so
for the most part for me like if a girl
looks really good on paper i'm not
interested but if she's got all sorts of
red flags
then like i'm very attracted that's like
the arousal template is hit oh my god
the one he's only had one girl that that
made him lose his mind
and
it was the gnarliest yeah that was the
one that he couldn't but the ones that
are like really healthy for me i'm just
like i can't breathe i gotta get out of
it really yeah i'm sort of the same way
i'm now that i'm a little older how old
are you 39. how old are you 48 in two
weeks you guys both look so much better
than me i'm 40 though you should be fair
enough dad i think you look fantastic
thanks this cause you haven't jerked off
in a while
oh yeah dude [ __ ] i get attracted to
um crazy [ __ ] make my dick move i you
know how they say like uh girls will go
from like a beta to an alpha beta alpha
my my pattern is crazy normal crazy
normal and the crazy girls that i date
are [ __ ] batshit like it's the purge
and the it's like the the dance yeah
it's the it's because you're like
it's like a sexual anorexic they'll be
like okay i'm gonna go like somebody who
abstains from sex because it makes them
disgusting and it's been like a year
like i should probably have sex again
yeah and then they [ __ ] like 10 times in
a week and they're like i can never do
that again and they'll go another year
without it it's like that constant yeah
and i have an extreme sort of
personality like that as well but yeah
the crazy girls are i'm just at this
point dude i recognize like i'm not
going to be like i used to get into
crazy arguments with girls i used to
punch holes in my walls like a lunatic
dude i mean
the amount of times just doing stupid
[ __ ] like i would never hit a girl ever
in my entire life the amount of times
that i've hit myself because a girl has
driven to the point where i need to
punch something like it's [ __ ] it's
cr i've had so many of those
relationships when i was in my
teens and 20s where that was me
if a girl
if a girl brings out any crazy me at all
i see it as a red flag and i run in the
opposite direction now i can't i'm too
much to lose i have i have a kid now i
can't let my kids see me being a [ __ ]
crazy person
so i'm only texting with eight
like normal chicks
but now the idea would be to like find
the pattern in these women that cause
you to do that so you don't even get
past the first date yeah yeah maybe yeah
you're right well that's the other thing
is like you know as you're saying that
like yeah i you're like date i just [ __ ]
no no i like dating too dude i like
going on a date i like going on a date
like bringing a chick out to a nice
restaurant
going to [ __ ] you go to a nice bar
classy place
chicks love that [ __ ] dude yeah it's
like it's like dexter
like he he doesn't like the actual
murdering he likes setting up the entire
[ __ ] scene yeah well that's the
ritual yeah it is the ritual and now
that it's like it's like buying coke
but you're like the best part is like
driving over there and like scoring and
then when you do it you're like god why
did i do that the best part about the
best part of coke
no wasn't
the drive over i think it was doing all
of the coke
the best part was three days in
when uh
yeah after three days of being awake and
doing the coke and so you finally
finished it and now you're actually
committing yourself to go to sleep and
then when you jerk off
oh that's a vegetarian three days into a
car oh no i hate jerking off on coke
dude i don't do coke anyway i've done
coke in at least a year and a half
um i i hate it dude people try to give
me free drugs all the time ketamine i i
love ketamine
it's not even it's not even a come down
you just [ __ ] you're done you can go
i'm gonna do like ketamine's a new york
thing right like
he's a new york thing i don't know
nobody remembers me pcp but i can't i
whatever it is i don't
i'm actually at a place right now where
i think i like life because i don't want
to remove myself from this head space
and i smoke weed and i drink but i'm not
like like smoking weed is almost the
same way people smoke cigarettes i just
smoke weed very i'm a pothead so it
doesn't get me stoned per se
but i like i just like where my life is
at and i like what's going on you know i
feel like when i was doing coke and when
i was doing a lot of different drugs i
was genuinely trying to escape i was
just trying to [ __ ] be on a different
plane you you were the one who scored
the acid to dose ari
a fan gave it to me yeah
acid's probably pretty hard to get at
one of the skank fests right no please
that's back in a big way too
everywhere dude it's like when uh i was
in colorado uh does anybody have any
weed right now
this comedian that was opening for me
says uh
we're in denver and he says man i'm
thinking about trying weed but where am
i gonna find that around here
well what's funny is that you said uh
you know
it's like when you you get a coke and
you're on a three-day bender and the
coke's finally out it's like how much
coke were you buying to [ __ ] take you
three days to do it all right i would
typically get an 8-ball and then like
need another 8-ball as soon as that one
was done in the second 8-ball then i was
like okay now i can now i can sleep for
a day [ __ ] dude why did you just buy two
eight balls at once i mean if i had any
common sense i'd buy a [ __ ] quarter
pound but the problem is
yeah
no the problem is you buy that much
you're doing that much right exactly um
yeah it was it was due to still gross i
was i was really into coke for a while
it was a very very dark time it wasn't
even like five do it by myself i would
it was [ __ ] sad luckily when i was in
the coke
um i was broke i was so broke and it was
just like i just i couldn't afford a jet
i was doing like four or five days a
week and i was spending everything that
i had on it um if i had a coke problem
when i had a little bit of cash
yeah i got that that'll take a huge hole
yeah i'm sure yeah yeah yeah it's
[ __ ] crazy yeah because because i did
uh
i i had quite a
number of years where i had expendable
income and a cocaine problem that sucks
that sucks it's really like luckily god
uh or whatever i was super professional
you know i never showed up late for a
job
i but it it would always turn into [ __ ]
i need another eight balls so that i can
show up to this job you think you spent
over a hundred thousand dollars in coke
probably and
um
and and i i heard this uh
i i heard that
one dollar bills change hands so much
that there's like lots of germs on them
that like to roll up a one dollar bill
and put it in there it's a risk for
hepatitis b sticking that in your nose
oh really i i heard that but but 100
bills don't change hands as much so it
was a cleaner bill so i i would make the
habit of of rolling up 100 bills to
snort coke and i probably my cocaine
habit cost the most from
leaving leaving rolled up 100 bills
everywhere yeah
jesus yeah you don't think about that
yeah i did that a lot yeah it's [ __ ]
up it's a great i think it's i'm that's
what i'm most embarrassed you want to
see the like that's where i think about
shame i think about where you spend your
money
just no just having like that much of a
a coke problem i remember was going on a
date with a chick once
and uh she wasn't doing coke but i was
like i'm gonna go do coke in the
bathroom and like i just did it and i
was like how could she possibly [ __ ] me
at the end of that date she did but like
what's that like it's a crazy like it's
crazy that that i look at that now i was
like how would you her dad was probably
a drug addict probably maybe man
it's like
how could she [ __ ] me after this i mean
she did what a loser what is wrong with
her why would you do that that's the
classic groucho marx i would never want
to be a member of a club that would have
me as a member
yeah dude well cool man i think we're
like
we're pretty pretty deep in like uh
i i'm stoked
i think i might steal this from mike
tyson from now on forever
like at the end of the podcast with him
he said uh
there are millions of people what do you
want to say to them
pretty cool
uh
thanks for watching and uh you know
[ __ ] uh get on that [ __ ] support
get on that uh that high level of
felonious assault with with lsd
hilarity
get some lsd
you're friends with
the people you love the ones that trust
you specifically right why not but
enjoy the whole hilarious series it's
just great comedy it is really funny and
big j he i know that he big j is funny
first so i know he thinks it's worth it
but i got a lot of live stuff coming up
my website is lewisofskanks.com i'm
touring all over the world really great
um and uh yeah i do stand up i do live
podcasts and uh yeah and and uh this
website where they're gonna find your
tour dates is louisofskanks.com
and the next skank fest is october 14th
or 16th it is completely sold out but if
you guys follow me on social media we do
giveaways all the time we do you know
fun contests we're doing uh
yeah we're doing a bunch of really cool
unique contests to win tickets so yeah
keep on tuning in cool all right man
dude i'm i'm super stoked to the man
thank you yeah dude nice to meet you too
and you don't want anything edited out
no
what did i say
i know if that was an option i wouldn't
have talked about all these eight chicks
that i'm seeing
no regrets remember
no regrets all right dude thanks bro oh
yeah
and here we are one more time at the end
of the podcast with the most special
people those of you who stuck around to
the end of the podcast
and man that was pretty crazy firing
shots at full send
and you know what
those [ __ ] [ __ ] had their run it's
time for yeah dude right
i'm telling you i do love steve will do
it and uh i will say he doesn't send
[ __ ] but he sure is full spend
getting props for that i love you steve
will do it and hey man i'm just trying
to get somewhere in the world so
everybody [ __ ] go to stevo.com and
pre-order this [ __ ] and ass jersey
yeah dude